- [Voiceover] Some
students traveled by train,
airplane, or boat during the summer.
This bar graph shows how many students
used each type of travel.
All right, let's look at this thing.
All right, so it tells us
that five students traveled by train.
It tells us that 10 students
traveled by airplane.
Two students traveled by boat.
Then we're asked how many
more students traveled
by airplane than boat?
Well let's see, 10 students
traveled by airplane,
two traveled by boat.
So how many more is 10 than two?
Well we could figure that out by saying,
well what's 10 minus two?
So 10 minus two is going
to be equal to eight.
Eight more students traveled by airplane
than by boat.
And you could even see it in the bar graph
that if you wanted to go from the two
who traveled by boat to the 10
who traveled by airplane, you would have
to add one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
So eight more traveled
by airplane than by boat.
Let's keep going.
Sunny, Rover, and Buster buried,
Sunny, Rover, and Buster buried bones
in the backyard, or in the yard.
This bar graph shows how many bones
each dog buried.
All right, so Sunny buried 10 bones.
Rover buried three bones.
Buster buried seven bones.
How many fewer bones did
Rover bury than Sunny?
Let's see, Rover buried three bones,
Sunny buried 10 bones.
So how many fewer is three than 10?
Well to go from 10 to three
you have to take away seven.
10 minus seven is three,
or 10 minus three is seven.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So Rover buried seven
fewer bones than Sunny.
10 minus three is seven.
The difference here is seven.
Seven.
Let's do one more of these.
Let's do one more.
The weather in November
was sunny, cloudy, or rainy.
This bar graph shows the number of days
of each kind of weather.
All right.
So we have 18 sunny days in November.
We have seven cloudy days in November.
We have five rainy days in November.
How many rainy days
were there in November?
Well I just said it.
Look at the rainy category,
and this bar graph shows us
it goes all the way up to five.
There were five rainy days in November.
We got it right.